you've spoken this weekend about feeling
unfairly treated and scrutinized by the
rest of the world what do you mean by
that
look i think it's uh
i think looking at a situation from one
perspective is easy to do and
everyone
is is free to look at things that they
that they want to see the way they want
to see it i think when we when we say
unfairly treated is basically not
looking at
situations in
context not looking at the immense
amount of uh progress that has happened
to date and obviously here we're talking
about workers welfare in in qatar
qatar has been a trailblazer in
improving workers rights improving
workers
standards of living introducing of
minimum wage
abolishing the kafala system
[Music]
you know working hard i know that the
supreme committee has been working hard
for all workers on the construction
sites to make sure that their workers do
not pay recruitment fees and they're
sending country from descending
countries um the supreme committee has
reimbursed
many of the workers that have been able
to prove that they've paid unfair
recruitment fees back in their countries
as someone who is trying to stage a
football tournament
how do you feel about repeatedly
facing these questions
you know the world cup is uh
you know it's a global event it puts
countries
in the spotlight and i know that a lot
of
entities you know use it as a as an
opportunity and it's something that the
government and the country has expected
um the for
the ferocity of it is what hasn't been
expected it's been a ferocious
10 years
of you know fighting back trying to
um
you know put clarity out there to make
making sure that the story comes out
across
but
this is the reality of of the situation
here i mean a lot of people listen a lot
of people
come to qatar to see the facts for
themselves unfortunately a lot of
entities that do put out these reports
don't even bother coming here and seeing
things for themselves
we know that
of the teams that have qualified
already some have made statements around
the importance of human rights
we've been speaking to the head of the
danish fa who i think has been in
contact with yourselves
about how
receptive
the organizers of the tournament will be
to players and teams
wanting to make a point about human
rights
again i mean this is obviously anybody
who wants to take a position
on whichever topic is their personal
right and
what we've been engaging with
different federations uh
the nordic the um a lot of uh
face in europe and elsewhere
um invited them to see things for
themselves to look at the progress
that's been made over the 10 years
many of them recognize the progress are
quite happy to see the amount of
progress that's been made over the past
10 years
and you know like i said it's it's it's
their position it's their right to have
these positions and the important thing
for them is to take these positions
with full information
and and
information that we're able to show them
and share with them and i think that's
what's important for us
is not to take a position based on
um on on the news
have the english fa been in part of
those discussions with yourselves now
that gareth southgate and his team have
qualified
um i think the english fa has been an fa
that we've been engaging with for a very
long time the supreme committee and the
qatar football association has been you
know in frequent engagement with the
english fa
and congratulations on qualifying
and we know fans
want to come and enjoy the world cup and
in many cultures that involves alcohol
what is the
the message that you would have for fans
who want to come and drink alcohol in
qatar
and also those fans who will do it
perhaps away from the designated areas
where you would like them to drink
look first of all what i want to say is
is alcohol is legal and available in
qatar it might not be as readily
available as
other parts of the world where alcohol
is is
an integral part of culture
however we are a hospitable country and
hospitable people and we respect other
cultures and and uh you know we are
making it more available in in
designated areas that fans want to go to
it's available in hotels uh we are
confident that this will not be an issue
as as
you know as people perceive it to be
we know that football fans
particularly in
europe and particularly in some other
parts of the world
do get carried away and do
really enjoy themselves
and get sometimes very drunk
how much
do those fans need to bear in mind the
place where they are
for this world cup
generally what i've seen from fans
traveling to world cups is that they're
quite uh
um respectful to cultures um
that's not always the case nasa
what i've been to the past previous
three world cups and i can tell you that
what what i've seen is um
fans are generally
in
joyous moods they're always supporting
their teams they get they get a little
bit rowdy but nothing that i've seen
that goes beyond that to be honest with
you
so there's there's nothing to worry
about i know that there's uh
um plans in place to make sure that
people really have an enjoyable time
whatever it is
um
um
that fans like to do it's uh
we just need to make sure that it's
within the parameters of what's uh
what's legal and what's safe their
safety and the security is paramount
the
everybody's welcome slogan is one that
is is well
known now around qatar 2022.
um
what do you say to
fans that and we've speak spoken some
fans from lgbt
q plus groups who say that they just
don't want to travel because they don't
want to go to a country where their
sexuality is against the law
look what we want to say is uh first of
all that everyone well everyone's
welcome is not a slogan it's it's it's a
fact everybody is welcome
we we're not making any differentiation
based on
race
gender
orientation
religion
everybody's welcome